2021 home prices surged in many areas
squeezing out millions of would-be
homebuyers looking for their piece of
the american dream well guess which u.s
city has the least affordable housing
right now new york san francisco no not
at all mark strossman went out to find
the answer you might be surprised
here's how you buy a home in boise beg
the seller to let you overpay put this
in here
i actually don't even know what's in
here max hampton and kelsey taylor
pleaded with her seller and bought their
first home after three months of
rejected offers
oh good multiple houses almost every
single day and then making some fast
decisions yes like where we couldn't
even sleep on it we would have to
say okay we have to figure this out
within the next hour but for many buyers
boise has become america's most
unaffordable housing market one study
compared boise's median priced home
almost
535 000
that's 10 times higher than the median
income for one person here almost nine
times higher than the median income for
a couple prices went up 30 percent in a
year here in ada county it's just it's
incredible agent jennifer louis showed
us all the current listings for half
million dollar homes there are 24 homes
in this entire city city
and how many buyers would you guess for
the 25
maybe a thousand and it's been
completely
insane why insane there just wasn't
enough inventory so anytime somebody
wants to come here and buy a house it
was just an absolute you know kind of
feeding frenzy
bidding wars all cash offers above
asking price virtually standard the
pandemic brought a surge of investors
and virtual workers from neighboring
states snapping up homes driving up
prices you see a lot of license plates
from oregon washington california
michael miller and kelly goritz are
ready to sell and move to north carolina
have you had unsolicited offers
yes how many offers have you had
probably dozens it doesn't matter to
them that the garage door doesn't work
or
maybe the faucet drips
you know it's not a big deal they know
that's something they can fix older
sellers cashing in younger buyers
squeezed out moving away
it's changed the behavior of the city to
a degree people drive differently who
come from out of state the locals are
giving california place the side eye
get idaho plates if you move here from
california
max and kelsey got lucky their seller
wanted a local buyer if the seller of
this house was only interested in the
best offer i would still be looking yeah
oh for sure for sure yeah
metro boise's known as the treasure
valley these days the name fits
for cbs mornings mark strassman boise
idaho
yeah that's a lot for anybody over 530
000 right half a million dollars for a
home and then when you hear the surge of
investors yeah as a big reason you see
that across the country you do i this
reminds me of bend oregon remember when
that hip little town
exploded now boise yeah i almost went to
college there went on a recruiting trip
i should have went to college and bought
some homes then we would have never met
you that's true that's true they need to
be rich
good trade-off all right here we go
let me put my business out there